[Music]
Uh
[Applause]
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music] I
prepared a presentation titled Skimming the
Olo Pet Code by the Chord Argument.  It is an element that makes it difficult to grasp the main interest difference and
unnecessarily organizes the programmer's mind and interferes with thinking.  I
try to avoid the bolo plate code,
but despite our constant efforts, we encounter golo plate flowers every day.  We have
prepared a
code factoring technique that will help
you gain an edge in the war against the plant coats.  Let's
start with * * A
long and key story about coding minutes
starts with the goal update code What is a polo plate code
Boiler cleat code is a code that is used repeatedly If any code is
used repeatedly, if it appears redundant, all the code is a plate plate  It can be called a code. Let's
take a look at a few examples.
Here are 2 rows,
Oh here Bear plus Motors, One number Thumb and Array, there are many even numbers, and this number is an online
function.
Can you find overlapping parts in Mr. Joongang's code
?  Let's change the code to make it easier to understand.
Now, do you see what the two have in common?  In the
case of SUM,
each element is continuously accumulated, asking whether an array is used, and in the case of this bus,
only paired elements are stored, asking whether an array is used.
This time, it is a different example.
Now, the function you started
can go to a function that returns different characters depending on the type of number.
What is the flute code in the hidden form of the code above? It
is a code that separates and investigates the number of cases for a value of 1.
In the case of doors, different characters are being performed depending on the type of case,
and from the neck, in this case, if the number 2 is possible,
for example, if it is 0, if it is a positive number, if it is a number, it is receiving different characters.  There
is one big problem, which
is when it causes unnecessary cognitive distress.
Let's talk more deeply about this topic.
What's inside the hotel?  Just as there is a
reader who reads the code, a program with a code, a
computer, and a
subject that is the content that the author wants to talk about line by line,
the code has an interest in the problem that the programmer wants to solve.  It
contains algorithms and concepts that are the way you want to solve this problem.
Code is vague enough to describe how to solve the problem.
So you can talk. Bad code has bad scratches.
Bad code is
bad code,
and convex plate is the main culprit in making bad code, which causes the cognitive load to speed up the code's interest.
There is
1 How to combine the number of ducks 2
How to pick out only the even numbers Write the array from the end or
write it from the beginning or 2 Whether to use s m l with turret side or
with index, in fact, again important for these functions  It's
not a factor I do
n't think I care. It's not that important to use now.
But if you look at our actual code, the code for how to do arrays
has about the same amount of code for subjective incidents in each receptacle.
If you look, the
belt code continues to relocate the program to the goal of the necessary information. You are
getting into an accident by hatching
inches so that you don't pay attention well.
Nonetheless, the district where I'm strong with convex plate code and 2-inch 9 episodes is significant
now because boiler plate codes scatter unnecessary information throughout the code base, and are now significant in overall cognitive load, and
most codes that will cause a print revival are in fact  It's a general purpose thing,
because it's a potentially widely used goallo quilt code.
So, what are some ways to get rid of baller plated codes?
Here are 5 programming paradigms, each with their own interesting approach.
In this process, the class code can be removed as a form, and
object-oriented programs can be written through objects, the 4th professional racer
through generics, meta programs through macros, etc.
Of these, we'll learn more about it in Chapter 17, Pro Maps, which is the most widely used method among campers. In other words, the
World Pro League approach is fundamentally based on data abstraction.
Abstract,
use objects directly and indirectly through inheritance exponents such as classes and fruit books, and allow
one object to be used in many forms through diversity.
Obviously, this approach to object-oriented unraveling is effective in lowering the structure harness of large-scale programs.
SimC 5 Object Chapter Pro Jinyoung
even has a very cool programming theory pop program design disclosure called Design Patterns,
but object chapter programs now have their roots in computation.  The chosen people called data abstraction, not Chusa.
Now I have paid attention. This point will result in my body program
showing a lack of abstraction in operation.
That's the topic of the day,
and that's function authenticity.
Functional programming is a
paradigm that has its roots in associative abstraction, not data abstraction, as opposed to dog exit frames.  This
is the paradigm we want to use as
8. Let's solve the abstraction of the first operation. Everything cool cuts it.
From now on, we will learn about shout programming as a new approach to boiler plate code.  Unlike
other programs, such as object and component deprecated, the function must hit the calling image, and
there is no object of association with the bulletin board constraint.
5 programs either way or our sarcophagus. This
suggestion  In Profeng, it is
also a functional programming student who accepted calculation as an object of operation.
If you have to limit this ahead of time, function investment that handles one number gives birth to mysterious functions.  This
is because the existing functions that only dealt with tuna advisory fee values ​​are higher-level functions in that they
deal with functions differently.  I will recommend the code that executed this code.
This code is originally a belt coordination with the thumb function that appeared in the previous example.
And if the array is the number of peers or 15, the
default star and the value to put out are 5.
Simply make 2 the elements of c as parameters, and the abstraction is
done.
Because it can be transmitted and received, it
became possible to be a caregiver for those cumbersome mountains that constitute a huge operation.
If the
concern about how to do iteration is reduced to a single line now,
give it a yellow line
and write it. How to do it further, which is the most important concern of waterproofing.
This time, I know the abstract code that examines the value with the number of cases.
This code is a rollerblade coordination for the stacked L-ssam number and the Thai kudden bo function that appeared in this example 3.  The
element to be checked is used when the value to be inspected
and the element to be
inspected are used.
Take a slightly different approach to .
First, the writing itself in each case is variable.
There are a total of 9 cases from level 1 to level 1.
In that case, the numbers must be expressed through the remaining parameters.  I
also expressed the number of operations to buy by running the two-plate distribution to be used as a test, but in the
case of the above case of a little desperate code, it is convenient to hold the source and show the test method as the
first element and the operation method as the second element.
Last  Again, the previous two are not important because they are ux problems, but if you
drink, the problem is the amount I want to do the
second time.
Most of the longevity who use codes that investigate values ​​with the number of are devices that do not know how the winter number is changed and what value actually came in.
Therefore, if the reaction of the operation is first, surgery is performed and then the irradiated
gas  I'll have you
step on it. Tell me, it hurts a little bit, so now I'll take a look at the
code. I'm on all fours. Isn't it simple?
When it comes, loop through the case and check the drink.
If the function that finds a place in the test method is called the prezi case,
it is a simple code to execute the operation.
5 4 Yes Well, I'm
worried as follows. I showed a much cleaner look. The
number of cases and the calculation for them fit in one
character. Yes, I took some time to think about the scene.  If
you look closely at the new code, it makes bottled water, and the shape of the mountains next year is very injectable.  You
can get it off with cheap toms.
Okay so that's much more satisfying.
Next, let's look at a little unusual high decapitation.  Let's
assume that there is a function c made of this.
It can be.
If so, the rain is xo, and the
back is also simple like f, so the tooth can rot easily, so the rest xl
will be more e.
But here x 2ea + the idea cpx vomit It's like life Yes,
we go through the ears  It can be seen that there is also a number h that is more than 3 between the group and the value.
And the operation of adding 3 to h as we saw when deriving h, the hydrochloric
acid adding 3 as we saw when deriving a is a function f  And and
can be further represented by a function c
Apply the apple of a first and then apply the rat again, then we
can get c from a as in h.  You
can express h like a pipe ch. You
can reduce a large number with small functions.
It's the same as
Ah, I
'll also look at the use of 1 now in this function.
For example, by
adapting the function of Cops to an array as follows, a new array is created, the function
Nek and Chick Pre extract the second smile, and the function Pace and the
number of object pop entries are wrapped.  It hurts to give me through 8 spaces.
The value of all properties of the object is obvious. You can make news. I will
briefly explain how this bell 3 works.  I
also soaked the fact that I wrote an image 8 It seems that the [ __ ] entry sul beer
message is going to
cross the base there as it is.
If you think about putting the 7th coat in the number of 3 body and body, you
can imagine right away. 4 Here, I'm going to run the of extent ace for now.
Nable Now, let's go back to the original code.
Yes, as follows, the array f changes the sng function, and the torpedo's
sng code changes to the array map sng code.  Let's
crash this code again  I'm sure some of
you are familiar with this.
Take my senses and get points on each element of the array. As a
result, this and 23 come out.
4 The function we'll be looking at this time is a bit
trivial and really trivial. It's simply a
function that just checks a given value.
But surprisingly, this function is the
greatest and most important function in shout programming along with the aforementioned pipe  It
may be difficult to derive, but this function
is a function that has a great value both in terms of use and at least experimentally.  There is
no time, and they are too complicated, so
let's look at one with a practical eye.  If you
combine Arms, the function will come out as it is. I
'll show you what it looks like from now on.
Here is the code to combine 2 Arms f and the identity into one pipe.
And here, when this eyed decapitation is actually pitiful and toothed with actual code, it is
as follows.
Then, focus on the low function and the value of fx applied to that xx function, and then
remove unnecessary parts in this part.  If you crash the code, it
is as follows
And finally, this code becomes f again. It
takes a value and executes the small apple with that value, and the function that produces the result is
actually no different from f. I just wrapped it and wrote it.
What is the important reason for this achievement? It is
because Seongsu Lee, as a criterion,
makes the instrument that uses Eyes Charm attractive.  There are times when senior players
fill in the rainy blanks with phenomena.
Hwaji or sometimes, there are times when you don't want to be the best at
some senior players.  It becomes that
he wants to do it, especially when he has nothing to do with our interests.
At the same time, if you
call the function aggregation, it will be easier. I
will show you a practical example. The
number of file farms I have just shown is
2 functions and tuples, and the function of each field is mapped. 1
function is applied to the Jeju pool.  If you use an abstract window
and this function takes 10% of the first 10% of the fields, only the function maps
1 to
4 when Stam 459 Gives 459 So the
two remain conceptually and morphologically very similar
Macbeth Tams from Chia Bar  If you remove the chi and gy code from this map,
it will eventually be explored in nephew.
There are 3 boxes together. 5
If my Force Tams is the right value, and if you dance with f on the body of the release palms, there are
still blanks in the function and there are unbiased parameters, so it
becomes a cow with a hole in the body.
But if you put a function called ig here that has grown in size, Ira
can now make a complete map 1st function with a tieback function so that the function fills the hole. This is
how it becomes a basic number  At the point,
when the 1st generation body is called or a hole is drilled in the function, I don't think I will use it here later, but the number of
items lottery remains the same in that I use the same worry.  I'd like to
tell you about how to look at curry, dyne,
ginseng, ginseng, and 3. It's
easy to see. To put it more simply, culling requires a function that splits its arguments into a form that fits, and looks at it. Let's take a
simple example:
No currying this function. No, the
two arguments are split as follows.
Insul is divided several times to get out. There are
two main reasons for using this currying.
However, the part we pay attention to among these is the
first advantage. The second advantage is the first advantage.  It
is because there is 5 in the first joint to use as valuable as possible. If you are
curious about the second device, you can do it separately now, and you can look it up yourself.
So, for now, I'll pass it on.
There is a Leva function Medi,
this function will be really familiar to me in fact for all JavaScript 9 people,
and now that you are familiar with the function Array Jump, see you back in 4.1.  The
numbers made as enemies are correctly male and female.
Yes, if you change the order of the parameters of the function and then curry the function, it is
free with Rick T as follows.  The
reason for the difference
is that the interpretation of the congress about the role of the function is different. Let me
show you that Rick Toms's will be used differently now.  If the
rip times of this function are exceeded, you can create this function again with
Liquid. What is the difference between this two function?  I'm going to
separate from the separation,
put that sickle in my head, separate this year is called
ahh now I heard it at a glance.  How is it? I
simply split the arguments and changed them purely, but the
meaning of the functions has changed a lot.
At first, the function is important for arrays that just apply a function to each element of an array and judge the result, and there
is no function, but curling  And with a little bit of comfort, it has been reduced by raising this
simple value function to a higher-order function that lifts a function into an array as a child
function.  Let's
make it easy
4 So far, we've
looked at the basic children of the Shout Pro Ring that can help you kick off the plate code. In
addition to the previously introduced Pipe and Item Chickie, followed by the Curry, the Shout Promo now has an endless list of functions.
Through consideration, I can understand beautiful and really wise concepts. Unfortunately, due
to time constraints, I cannot introduce all of them, but for those who are more curious, I would like to
briefly introduce the concepts of Cima.  What
this
enemy is going to do is really contradictory, these contradictory students.  If you
want to become a doctor, I
strongly recommend that you do not look for the
loss function.  It is called
lifting. The
concept of recommendation 1 for other leaves that can be lifted
like this
is the putter.
Simple operation is abstractly divided. This
is actually a function that is too difficult for me to use simply,
but the reason why this game company wants to introduce it  It's
weather Arch Can you get a really deep insight into my arithmetic
and also shout crohn's In fact, the technique that works the most in removing the gold plate code
is 1 skill.  If you
want to study more, I recommend you to take a look at this concept. The
last one is not op.6. Optics
is already a university of relationships in terms of the structure of and the part that can be controlled without its good.
Also, it can be explained through this concept. I
don't know if you have heard of the concept of sense. You are
Lee Ok-hee x Eve.  I
strongly
recommend that you take a look at it.
Now, there are 2 good materials related to city gas. Now that you have cleaned the city gas, those who have studied should
use it.
It was not good because there was no
writing, but the good things to look at are always the pro's talent, and there are cases where the concept is really like fighting and moisture.  It's
all about the story.
From now on, I'm going to wrap up the presentation by talking about other stories in today's presentation.
First of all, we
looked at the
ballo flat code.  I have a
problem that causes unnecessary cognitive resurgence,
and as a way to deal with it, I
looked at several methods, including unraveling the
cup of
wit.  As for the old-timers, this concept has now been introduced.
And then, the function Fate and the special sword item Chichi, which will lead to the third number, and
finally, the function is introduced as a curry ring, a method of spawning at different times.
This is our content.
Finally, I would like to
conclude. Now, in this presentation, I
briefly looked at how to access the baller plant code through functional premiere.
Chapter 3 programming
can be used as an enemy with the idea that the proposed fring preload program flies greatly as a gas. There
are largely two ways to solve the
quadratic equation.  It's a similar
method
Which of the two is better Do you know immediately
But, it is not very efficient when it is not easily factored in at a given time or when two pennies are insignificant.  It
gets complicated every day.
On the other hand, if you use the formula, you
can solve this much easier because you just need to put the numbers in a fixed
frame.
This method makes a little uncomfortable feeling, but it
can be used to solve the plate coat by solving the yo function, and the
causal and gas fields are the same.  There
is a saying, "don't blame"
This word can be interpreted as "a person with skills does well no matter what tool he gives", but it
can belong a little differently.
This is also possible.
I think it would be ideal to use various tools in the right place at the right time rather than sticking to a certain method, estimating it, and using it only for human programming,
so I would like to say one last thing to you.  Let
's be amazing Thank you so much for listening